here come the boys this is not only
bagel boss guy but bagel boss's manager
bagel boss's boxing promoter he went
from being a guy no one really knew to
now he has two people in his entourage
Chris you want to get a fight with Julie
but who is the one that you're promoting
now isn't there some fight that you have
lined up with a some sort of youtube
star yes so what happened was when I met
Michelle I saw Julie I know I'm outside
the studio here a few weeks ago I said
surely you got to fight this guy and
we're in schooi let me i think surely
could beat you up no offence I say you
think you can really take him III have a
pretty good uh yeah I think so
I think no offense I mean the height
differential I know but that don't mean
[ __ ] surely you originally turned down
the offer for the fight am I correct yes
but we know that this would be a big
fight because Chris is right now on the
top of his fame Wow I'm ready to sign
them right now Julie come on
and how much do I owe you after I don't
want to press you into this kind of
thing real seriously yeah you know
that's up to you whether you want to
fight Chris no Howard I think you should
oh really
yeah Julie I want you your mind God
surely come on come on be a man I've
been you seen my content over there's
mr. button shirt I don't want to fight
Chris right I I want to fight the people
that made him famous and now that he's
here on a show that those are the people
I'd like the fight I think his 15 inches
of fame is up it's over actually though
I what about it though wouldn't it be
good for you and your career he's the
same height as my four-year-old if I
beat him up I'm a monster how I like to
retort in the Iron Sheik fashion Canada
but that was pretty good see you guys
back to back don't Mike Tyson Tyrell
Biggs or Buster Douglas
can you beat him up of course I can't
you give me I put my hand on his head
and hold him there and then I punch him
with the other one like they do to a
child how to admit in some strange way I
do think you would win I know I would
he's catching a football and track anger
that he's bringing to the fight though
and my 3 1 minute rounds come on shore
what kind of money is in this for you is
there any incentive that way well I
talked to Damon I gave him my number you
did yeah and and what happened Damon
you're booked well he I forget what the
exact number he had but I think when we
agree to pour talked about was a good
amount of my how much money I'll
negotiate for surely well I was
originally gonna say five thousand five
thousand that rounds the story yes
that's a nice we rent one minute rounds
well you look for more like 10
yeah Howard I make that telling jokes
for now right so why go why go to get in
a boxing ring we punched with sneezy
over
[Music]
there's a number if you want me to go
when I see down to this level then I'm
gonna make some money it's not down the
global I'm building one comic I'm not a
[ __ ] viral guy yelling at a [ __ ]
comics voice before so truly are you
backing down off the fight are you
interested we're Lee where is your head
at now that you see Chris face to face
and he's calling you out and saying he
wanted to fight with you here's the only
way it happens okay go ahead the number
amount that I gave Damon is Matt is
Matsui 30 grand
oh come on man well the room wouldn't
even fit that much
that's okay well I'll give you a
guarantee off the back end - that's all
I could do off these eiffel's offer what
back in and how do I figure out what the
back end is who's bringing negotiate our
that's our Chris does it sound like Shu
Li is scared to fight you is that what
it sounds like in your here let me look
at this look up I'm over here come on
man seriously look I put a lot of effort
into this what I think you're good
pickups on a bench I'll run circles
around you you see the punches I was
drawing a look went to Jim yeah I saw
well there you go
I think you're scared look at me I look
like a tantrum yeah you look like a
scared little wuss let me see you throw
a few punches if you don't mind it you
let me see what this guy's got Robin
you're a boxing fan yeah however you
have to do it just stand there and throw
a few like a shadow boxer
let me see what you do let me see go
ahead that's what what is that that's
blocking
oh that's blocked was he having a
seizure whoa look at that no come on
look at that look at this go get wipeout
look whoa I was impressed
thank you I was impressed what you think
free one minute round Shirley come on
not even winded let me see you do it let
me tell you that's not easy
go ahead oh my god he's gonna get beat
now look like a drowning surely no
offense what I saw Chris doin is
fisticuffs boxing the art of boxing I
see you just goofing up yeah I thought
that was boxing like a guy who couldn't
swim in the deep you're so confident
that you could beat me man if you won't
try to humiliate me
step up I'm not looking to humiliate you
I'm just looking if I'm gonna do
something that's out of my wheelhouse
then I'm gonna make some [ __ ] money
for it I got the contract right here
Shirley come on Shirley just sign the
[Laughter]
don't even read it Howard my weed dealer
day goes to B you're gonna fight the hot
dog guy or what that's how over it is
you're the hot dog I feel Christmas fame
is over it's done it's done look at the
source Howard it's coming from him I'll
give you a guaranteed ten thousand not
once but everything's paid off we'll
work another percentage off the back end
through Howard Stern it's all about
Howard Stern this is a big buildup I
think you'd be better off going to some
other offers buddy I appreciate you
there it is Shu Li is backing off on
Chris's fight I don't know if it's gonna
happen yeah we can't make Shirley take
the fight